listen logan i got to tell you i
thoroughly enjoyed you
as grandpa monster i felt like you were
just like feeling it
you were in the pocket and even though
you were in this mascot uniform
i feel like the judges were vibing with
you us watching at home reviving with
you
did you have as much fun as it looked
like um
i did it was nervous fun at first uh but
i ended up falling in love with the show
and the moment i fell in love with being
on the show
i got eliminated you were like i just
got there
dude i called my publicist after or
before the first round
i was like i can't believe you convinced
me to do this i can't sing
i'm embarrassing myself like i'm i'm in
an orange marshmallow costume like
literally like
get me off this show and then i didn't
get eliminated it was
caitlyn jenner got eliminated the first
round and uh then suddenly i fell in
love with it i was like
like the idea of possibly winning more
excited me so i really invested my
energy into it and then i got eliminated
[Music]
you could tell because you really did
bring the energy like even in your
dancing i saw your feet moving like
crazy and
i can't imagine what like how much that
costume weighed but you still pulled
through
i had to because i am not a i'm not a
singer like i
have i have like a bit of like a tone
kind of
uh but when there's no auto-tune on you
know i'm this
is me it's all i got and it wasn't
enough because
i don't know if you can tell but i'm
competing against actual singers which i
didn't know i go in
uh one morning and and uh black swan is
the trailer next to me
okay and she i i hear her warming up and
i knew
i'm screwed i i never stood a chance
when you hear those vocal warm-ups
you're like oh someone is really
practicing right now before this like yo
she really cares
and i'm i'm in there like eating like
cheetos on the sofa like crying that i
can't sing
no listen robin told you you brought
some personality to it though and that's
kind of key because no one can see you
you know you really gotta kind of
channel but
but key for what dude because i lost i
know i'm sorry
you're really bummed about it aren't you
you know i
it affected me you know the moment i got
attached
i lost so it affected you but did it
inspire you because you did
say that grandpa monster kind of helped
you find some confidence
with your voice like are you about to
drop a single is logan going to go
into the music industry are you inspired
no no
no that is fair i i i will say uh no
inspired isn't isn't the right word um
i think just like excited and thankful
to be on the show or
you know i i was excited to be able to
be
semi-vulnerable in in a costume because
the anonymous nature of the show is is
nice you feel free in a costume that is
incredibly restrictive
like it's hard to move it's hard to see
it's hard to speak
let alone sing and dance it was crazy it
was it was a challenge
so crazy uh you know on the show you
revealed that your childhood crush
was the rock i mean does that still
stand is that still the case does dwayne
johnson do it for you
look i told him betty white at first and
then they're like
and then i was like halle berry she
she's bad
right and then they said like and then
so i went with the rock look i love the
rock
yeah i don't know if he's my childhood
crush you know i love the rock like i
don't know
i just aligned with your storyline i
think is is why they probably want to
just i love his career path
well speaking of career path i do want
to talk to you about some other things
you're working on
uh talk to me about what fights or
matches you have coming up uh
you know it's the big bad dog the
greatest fighter on the planet man i'm
i'm going against floyd mayweather
uh and they're saying he's pretty good
this guy they're saying
i hear you guys they're good things
about him they're saying he's never lost
these are the rumors that i
i feel so dangerous i feel so confident
um
i don't know if i've ever felt more
confident about anything in my life
okay i'm uh i'm a dangerous fighter man
i uh i've been doing well i've been
doing it for three years now and no
one's seen me fight for
over a year and it's all i've been doing
and you know uh
you learn a lot when you lose i i would
almost be more afraid of the man
who's lost and is determined it also has
nothing to lose
like think about it i don't have
anything to lose i lose against floyd
mayweather
who cares right you fought for
mayweather i win against floyd
mayweather i'm the greatest fighter of
all time
there's a lot there's a lot of there's a
lot of freedom in that i love i love
that attitude it's win-win for you and
plus you're fresh off of losing the mass
singer so i feel like you're hungry
for a win dude i i'm honestly i'm just
thankful i didn't lose the first round i
i came home skipping i walk in the house
i go my roommates are like what
what's wrong what happened i was like i
didn't lose again
i am having a red carpet premiere
for my documentary trailer my guest of
honor global youtube sensation
logan paul yeah um yeah
so sami zayn uh the wwe superstar
invited me out to be a special guest for
his red carpet premiere of
his documentary so yeah i'm gonna fly
out for tampa
uh on my birthday in two days oh nice
you know
i mean i don't know what i don't know i
don't know what we're doing
um i think he's just gonna show me show
me his documentary and we'll
i don't know we'll see what happens okay
i was gonna ask you what you had planned
for your birthday but it sounds like
you're working
and i'm always working yeah nothing
planned i you know to
i'm not i'm not a big birthday guy
you're not well it's on april fool's and
so people
tend to like play pranks on me like i
i happened to be the butt of the joke
and it became unfunny after like
20 years it's my least favorite holiday
yeah man my least favorite birthday
ever
you